I think this is perhaps the biggest
breakthrough in environmental politics
since I don't know what because all of a
sudden we can connect the impacts of
everything we buy and know what they are
instead of not knowing and therefore not
having any say in the matter and we can
we can do three simple things we can
know the impacts of the stuff we buy we
can favor improvements and we can tell
other people what we've just done and if
we do that well we will begin a market
mechanism i believe that will ripple
through supply chains and upgrade how
people operate in business because as
market share shifts it changes the
internal discussion in companies where
right now there are some people who
think hey we should be more sustainable
in how we operate and the reply is will
show me the business case it's not going
to pay but as customers start to say I
care about this I'm not going to buy the
shampoo with that carcinogen I'm not
going to buy your hamburger that's
destroying the Amazon I'm not going to
buy this I'm not gonna buy i'm going to
buy anything that's better all of a
sudden what you've done is mobilized
innovation mobilized ways to improve
things for business because that's where
the market is going so what it does is I
actually help those of us who care about
the environment about it our health and
our family's health about the conditions
of the people who make our stuff it
helps us help people in companies do the
right thing it's kind of a virtuous
cycle
you